On October 5, 2017, in downtown Hereford,
England, 27-year-old Harry Godsall was going
about his day as usual.
He had taken a day off from his office job
to catch up on some errands, and it was all
going swimmingly so far.
He had woken up early to make a lovely cup
of tea and take his dog for a walk and had
noticed how nice the weather was for the time
of year, with hardly any of the usual rain.
After a rich, fulfilling morning of finishing
up the dishes and laundry at his flat, he
was taking a walk to the corner grocery store
to pick up some milk, potatoes, and ground
beef for the shepherd’s pie he planned to
make for dinner.
All in all, it was a good day to be Harry
Godsall.
Surely nothing strange or unusual would come
along to derail this perfectly pleasant and
ordinary day.
Out of nowhere and into what was meant to
be Harry Godsall’s day to himself suddenly
strolled a truly odd sight: walking down the
sidewalk toward him was a person in a full
spacesuit, like those worn by NASA and International
Space Station crew members.
In the middle of Hereford, casual as you please,
was an honest to god Spaceman.
Harry attempted to walk around this bizarre
figure and carry on with his day, but it deliberately
blocked his path and spoke with a booming
voice, asking if he would be willing to join
in the fight against “the Moon Monsters.”
Well, at this point Harry had just about enough
of this nonsense and his natural penchant
for sarcasm came out.
“Oh absolutely, you nutter,” he said.
“I’m ready to go right now, got my toothbrush
and everything.
Let’s fly, spaceman.”
He rolled his eyes, and once more attempted
to pass the astronaut.
Rather than taking the hint, the figure was
overjoyed.
“At last!”
It declared.
“A brave warrior, hiding in plain sight
amidst these pastoral and bucolic humans!
Let us away, fair meat-fellow, and earn the
glory of heroes!
We fly!”
Before Harry could turn and run away from
what was certainly not an ordinary man, the
spaceman grabbed him, pulling him into its
unnaturally strong arms, and activated the
jetpack strapped to its back.
There was a massive sonic boom, shattering
every piece of glass in a 300-meter radius
as they took off into the sky at a speed of
25,000 kilometers per hour.
They broke through the atmosphere and ascended
into space, so quickly that surrounding observational
satellites could not get a clear image of
the two on their journey.
Harry Godsall had been on an ordinary quest
to have a day of chores and a hearty dinner,
and now he had vanished into outer space.
His body was never found, and he could not
be positively identified on any satellite
images.
The residents of Hereford had their minds
wiped with amnestics by the SCP Foundation
in order to keep the story from getting out,
and Harry Godsall was officially declared
missing.
Three months later, when no trace of him had
surfaced, he was presumed dead.
To this day, he has never been found.
It is uncertain what he saw on his trip into
the stars, or what became of him.
All that we know is, on that fateful day,
Harry encountered the entity known as SCP-1233,
also known as The Lunatic or The Moon Champion.
SCP-1233 is a humanoid entity of unknown species,
wearing a spacesuit resembling the EMU - or
Extravehicular Mobility Unit - model, complete
with an opaque visor and attached jetpack.
The suit does not behave like an ordinary
spacesuit, capable of withstanding small-arms
fire, anti-tank munitions, landmine blasts,
and exposure to incredibly high temperatures
including complete submersion in magma without
any visible damage.
No radio, microwave, or x-ray scanning has
been able to break through the material of
the suit.
The jetpack is outfitted with a high-powered
rocket propulsion system, capable of accelerating
up to 40,500 kilometers per hour, at a rate
of acceleration and deceleration that should
instantly kill any human wearing it.
In addition to its resilience, SCP-1233 displays
an anomalous level of physical strength, able
to lift and throw items up to a weight of
65,000 kilograms without exhaustion.
The Moon Champion is capable of cognizant
speech and is fluent in a large number of
languages, able to switch its language depending
on the dominant tongue of whatever area it
is in.
It communicates via a loudspeaker installed
in its suit, and speaks using flowery language
in a loud, authoritative voice that is usually
interpreted as male, though the gender of
the entity - if it even has a concept of gender
at all - is unknown.
It has a strong grasp of language, but, like
its behavior, its speech patterns are odd,
erratic, and sometimes completely impossible
to understand.
SCP-1233 appears every 4-5 years, each time
following a similar pattern.
First, the entity will fall from an unknown
height above the surface of the earth, falling
at a terminal velocity similar to that of
a small meteorite or a vehicle re-entering
the atmosphere.
As it falls, SCP-1233 will emit red-orange
thermal radiance, causing it to be mistaken
for a shooting star if its descent occurs
at night.
Then, it will crash-land on the ground, leaving
a large crater and causing a small earthquake
in the vicinity.
It tends to land within 7 to 30 kilometers
from a town, usually a smaller municipality
with a population of 30,000 or less.
Then, 1233 will climb out of its crater and
head toward the town on foot or by flight.
It does not ordinarily head directly to the
town and has been observed taking its time,
taking the “scenic route” if you will,
and engaging in a variety of random detours.
SCP-1233 has taken the time to inspect various
objects, including farm equipment, buildings,
and plants.
Occasionally it will pick these plants, and
has been observed plucking the petals from
a flower in what can only be identified as
an interplanetary variation on the classic
“he loves me, he loves me not” game.
Sometimes it will chase after insects, such
as grasshoppers and butterflies, demanding
that they stop and allow the entity to observe
them.
Once, it accidentally crushed a ladybug between
its hands and wept inconsolably for a duration
of 25 straight minutes.
In addition to interacting with insects, it
also attempts to speak to various animals.
It has been spotted attempting to interrogate
a cow about its motives, greeting a bird as
if it were the owner of a house it was perched
on the roof of, and asking a frog where the
nearest place to get “something good to
eat” was.
It is unknown what, or even if, the entity
eats.
It has been seen pulling root vegetables from
the ground or picking fruit from bushes and
trees and shoving them directly into its closed
visor, crushing them uselessly, in what seems
to be an attempt to eat them.
Naturally, this attempt is fruitless.
Do you get it?
My joke?
Fruitless?
Cause he- Ahem.
Anyway.
When it is not attempting to eat, or interact
with new life forms, SCP-1233 occasionally
will march directly into large bodies of water
such as lakes or ponds, then emerge from them
and shake the water off of its suit.
It will also stand completely still for durations
of up to several hours.
The reason for any of this behavior, like
basically everything else about the entity,
is unknown.
Once SCP-1233 has reached the limits of the
town, it will attempt to engage with the population.
Due to its curious nature, heightened strength,
and lack of any understanding of proper human
behavior, this often results in confusion,
disruption, and a great deal of property damage.
A typical example of SCP-1233’s interaction
with the general public is found in archived
security camera footage from a bakery in Saratoga
Springs, New York by the name of “Sam’s
Sweets.”
On August 9, 2009, SCP-1233 entered the café
and attempted to speak with its co-owner,
32-year-old Bob Parsons.
Parsons greeted the entity with a friendly,
if perplexed, attitude, presuming it to be
a cosplayer taking a snack break from a nearby
comic book convention.
The entity identified itself as “Moon Champion,
champion of the moon, defender of space justice
and destroyer of evil.”
After introducing itself, SCP-1233 asked Bob
if he was the President of Earth.
He was understandably amused by the question,
laughing hard enough to bring tears to his
eyes, and offered the entity a free cookie
in exchange for cheering him up.
SCP-1233 identified the cookie - incorrectly,
obviously - as a parakeet, and smashed the
confection uselessly into its unopened visor,
scattering crumbs all over the counter and
floor.
It then attempted to engage Bob in conversation
about the “moon monsters” that it was
dedicated to fighting in its homeland: “the
majestic and magnificent Moon Kingdom.”
SCP-1233 then asked if it could perhaps befriend
a dog and take it back to the moon, and attempted
to recruit Bob to fight alongside it against
the Moon Monsters.
Bob, with a great deal of polite confusion,
insisted that he had to stay on earth and
continue to run the bakery in order to keep
the citizens fed.
1233 thanked him for his time, bid him farewell,
and crashed through a concrete wall leaving
a distinct astronaut-shaped hole.
SCP-1233 spent the rest of the day wandering
into traffic and causing several accidents,
breaking through glass storefronts, challenging
a fire hydrant to hand-to-hand combat, making
a pile of stolen bicycles in the middle of
a public park, and collecting as many dogs
as it could hold, then attempting to use said
dogs as a type of currency to purchase even
more dogs.
Finally, after leaving all of this head scratch-inducing
destruction in its wake, SCP-1233 activated
its jetpack and took off out of the Earth’s
atmosphere, apparently returning to the Moon.
None of SCP-1233’s claims about the moon
have been verified, though the Foundation
maintains contact with Lunar Area-32 to keep
an eye out for Moon People, a Moon Kingdom,
and the Moon Monsters 1233 spoke of.
In the meantime, the Foundation is simply
doing its best to contain SCP-1233 and minimize
its damage as much as possible.
Because of the anomalous physical properties
of SCP-1233, there is no way to physically
contain it at this point in time.
Until a method of physical containment can
be found, secondary measures will be taken
to keep this lunar lunatic from causing any
more havoc.
Or, at the very least, reduce its levels of
havoc as much as possible.
There’s only so much havoc we can prevent
in this world, especially when you have an
astronaut plummeting from the sky on a semi-regular
basis.
The Foundation satellite observation network
ARGOS, or Atmospheric Reconnaissance Global
Observation System, enters priority 2 high
alert status once 3 years and 6 months have
passed since SCP-1233’s last appearance.
When 1233 is spotted in the upper thermosphere,
a Foundation Mobile Task Force will be deployed
in whatever populated area is closest to the
entity’s estimated landing point.
There, they will prepare to administer amnestics
and provide a cover story - such as: immersive
theatre piece, prank show, 2001: A Space Odyssey
remake - to any civilians who witness SCP-1233’s
arrival.
In addition to these measures, there is to
be a media blackout in place in order to prevent
knowledge of 1233 from spreading.
Task Force operatives are authorized to grab
the smartphones of any bystanders attempting
to take photos, videos, tiktoks, or any other
documentation of the entity, and promptly
smash them on the ground in front of them.
It’s not like they’re going to stay mad,
they’re all getting their memories wiped
anyway.
If SCP-1233 stays in the area for an unusually
long amount of time, a mass amnesticization
of the town or city where it landed may be
authorized.
Though the task force is permitted to interact
with civilians in order to slow the spread
of information and provide cover stories,
no interaction between Foundation personnel
and SCP-1233 is permitted under any circumstances.
Even if they think it would be really funny.
No matter how epic your moon man prank might
be, it is never worth your life.
Now go check out “NASA Lies?
SCP-2001 - Space Oddity” and “How To Actually
Beat SCP-3008 The Infinite Ikea” for more
SCP videos that’ll make you laugh rather
than scream!